now in just a couple of hours here you  do have a chance to give your input on  proposed regulation for public cannabis  lounges clark county officials will meet  once again at two o'clock this afternoon  to discuss those rules what they might  look like  right now the only legal place to smoke  or consume pot in public is the lounge  on tribal land  tyler klimas the executive director of  the cannabis compliance board says it's  very important for everyone to share  their opinion  public feedback and public interest is  good that helps us within a very open  and transparent process it helps us get  a a final product um that is  representative uh of the issues the  concerns and the wants of of the  communities across the state  says after today's meeting there is one  more workshop it's set up for next week  and then after that the compliance board  will finalize the regulations the first  lounges could open by the end of this  year